- So the new show Lopez vs. Lopez
is based on your lives, right?
- Yeah, it's loosely
based on our real life.
- Is that hard?
- Well, you know what,
I'm not gonna say it's loose
because I'm the one that did
all the (beep) that was wrong.
It's not loosely based.
- (indistinct)
- Is like, I know,
but I'm just saying, is that hard?
Like, to like, I don't know
like, it's hard for me sometimes
I write a lot about my
real life in songs, right?
It's hard for me to like rehash that.
Is that hard?
- Yeah, I would have
to say there are times
times where it is challenging,
but we're, I like to think, is that
this is such an opportunity to heal
and I've always wanted my
pain to mean something.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, as you've done
like, to reach out and
carry much as people
and know that healing isn't linear,
that you're not perfect and
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, just having empathy
you know, as you get older
you start to see your parents as people,
and you know, maybe you
understand some things
you don't have to forgive
them, but you can understand.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, going
backwards and healing
but also rebuilding something stronger
for the future.
- [Kelly} You're very healthy.
- I'm very therapized.
- I was like...
- Everyone's like, where have
you been, I'm like, therapy.
- That's amazing, I was like, wow.
- I would say that, I would say that
that message probably
conveyed much better in song.
(Kelly laughs)
- It sounds better if somebody sang
♪ You were never there for me ♪
(Kelly laughs)
As opposed to you were never there for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah,
no, if you lighten it
with a nice melancholy melody
(laughing)
- Yes, yes, exactly.
- But, it's good though
that ya'll have that
communicative, I wish
I would have had that.
Like, my father passed away,
so we never got that, and I tried so hard.
A lot of people really
want that and desire that
and don't get that.
- [George] Right.
- So, it's really remarkable and awesome.
- We be- we believe
you know the first show
had, had a different slant you know,
this is fathers and daughters
and that relationship is, is worth
you know preserving and trying to get back
if there's fathers out there not speaking
to their daughters.
Um, you know, I-I when I
was growing up was very
tough and people would just
disappear from your lives.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I finally realized that as an adult
that I couldn't and didn't wanna do that
or go down that road anymore,
and that this person right here
was the one love of my life
and the one I would never
let go for, for anything.
So, I would um...
(clapping)
- Oh wow, I love that.